professor richard dawkins welcome i am
very excited to talk with you today
about
evolution and the nature of information
inside the cell
behind me is this picture of darwin here
which i drew
in 2010 after
binge watching your lecture your
christmas lectures
at the royal institution that convinced
me that i need to read darwin
so i read darwin then i drew that
picture and i decided i was going to
switch careers
and try and teach this for a living find
some way to teach this
in a nice clear way the way that you had
been doing in those lectures because
those lectures were so it was inspiring
for me i did not know that we understood
evolution
as as well as we did because i am an
animator i decided that i would use
animation to teach genetics and
evolution before i could do that i had
to learn genetics and evolution so i
spent several years studying and then i
started the stated clearly project
we create an emissions for they're
targeted at middle school and high
school
aged students but they're actually used
by people
of all ages now and those have taken off
i mean now we have
millions of students that have watched
them it's hard to tell how many
classrooms
have adopted them because all i have is
youtube analytics but apparently it's
thousands of classrooms because
during the school days i have this huge
explosion and views we've got stuff now
in spanish and in arabic in a very real
way the the success of stated clearly is
part of your teaching legacy because it
was your series of lectures at the royal
institution
that got me on this whole project that
kick-started this whole project for me
that's very good to hear john i'm
delighted to hear all that especially
about the schools are adopting it
and i like the picture of darwin you've
done too that's a very melancholy
picture isn't it you sort of feel he's
a rather sad man yeah
the drawing was based on a photo that he
has up in his house
and i had read somewhere him saying that
it was
his favorite picture of himself so
that's why i chose this for the drawing
yeah yeah he's i mean
darwin's his the way he thought was so
when you read his book it's it's it's
wordy by modern standards right
but it's it's so well thought out
it's just the clarity of thinking that
he had was amazing and he really wanted
to be understood he was trying to be
clear
all the time and that memorable
characteristics surprisingly rare
oh i agree that is very rare but it's
something that i
recognize in your work which brings me
to today's topic
i wanted to go over a paragraph
in your book the river out of eden and
in that paragraph you talk about
genetic information you talk about
genetic information as digital
information
and you make a prediction in that
paragraph of the book
that i think hell it hasn't quite come
out
the way that you had maybe hoped and
that's
one of the things i really want to dig
into and discuss is the nature of
vitalism
today okay page 17.
after watson and creek we know that
genes themselves within their minute
internal structure
are long strings of pure digital
information
what is more they are truly digital in
the full and strong sense of computers
and cds
not in the weak sense of the nervous
system the genetic code is not a binary
code as in computers
nor an eight level code as in some
telephone systems but a quaternary code
with four symbols the machine code of
the genes is uncannily computer-like
apart from differences in jargon the
pages of a molecular biology journal
might be interchanged with those of a
computer engineering journal
among many other consequences this
digital revolution
at the very core of life has dealt the
final
killing blow to vitalism the belief that
living material
is deeply distinct from non-living
material
up until 1953 it was still possible to
believe
that there was something fundamentally
and irreducibly mysterious
in living protoplasm no longer
even those philosophers who had been
predisposed to a mechanistic view of
life
would not have dared hope for such total
fulfillment
of their wildest dreams that's that's an
amazing paragraph
the the thing i want to talk in there is
you know this digital revolution at the
very core of life
has dealt the final killing blow to
vitalism
and i don't know how things are in the
uk but here in the us
people have been instead of accepting
that you know final killing blow
they have latched on to this
concept of code inside the cell and that
is
that's become the new vitalism you know
i'm from oregon
and there's a lot of kind of the new age
religion there
and this is what one of my friends over
there said
she said information transcends matter
it is non-physical
it must be placed into matter by a
creative conscious agent
dna is proof that we are created by
consciousness
and that's she's a medical student so
she's
you know smart person a friend of mine
from tennessee says dna
contains real encoded information if we
trace information back to its source we
always
come to a mind never material processes
and then another friend of mine in
chicago says
dna is code all codes with origins we
know were designed
therefore the genetic code was designed
well it's a classic
circular argument your friend i think
the last one you read
said um all the codes we know
come from a design well it's not true we
know the dna code it doesn't come from
design
he's simply going around in a circle
there and
it really does deal the killing blow to
vitalism
i'd like to read can i go and get a book
um from 1930 actually
to show what i mean by vitalism in this
sense
yeah yeah this is um charles singer
uh a short history of biology and i
think it was probably in the 1930s the
definitive work on history of biology
uh and um i see yes it's the last
paragraph there's further despite
interpretations to the contrary
the theory of the gene is not a
mechanist theory
the gene is no more comprehensible as a
chemical or physical entity
than is the cell or for that matter the
organism itself
further though the theory speaks in
terms of genes as the atomic theory
speaks in terms of atoms
it must be remembered that there is a
fundamental distinction between the two
theories
atoms exist independently and their
properties as such can be examined
they can even be isolated though we
cannot see them
we can deal with them under various
conditions and in various
combinations we can deal with them
individually
not so the gene it exists only as a part
of the chromosome
and the chromosome only as part of a
cell if i ask for a living chromosome
that is for the only effective kind of
chromosome
no one can give it to me except in his
living surroundings
any more than he can give me a living
arm or leg
the doctrine of the relativity of
functions is as true for the gene as it
is for any of the organs of the body
they exist and function only in relation
to other organs
thus the last of the biological theories
leaves us where the first started
in the presence of a power called life
or psyche
which is not only of its own kind but
unique in each
and all of its exhibitions now that is
absolute rubbish from beginning to end
that is completely and utterly destroyed
by watson and crick
so to be clear i do agree with you that
watson and crick
and you know rosalind franklin and all
the others really did deal the final
blow to vitalism
with the discovery of the structure and
function of dna however
the public doesn't seem to recognize
this fact and that's why i feel like
it's so important that we talk about
this
i actually have a quote from watson and
crick it's their second paper
on dna and their study of the structure
of dna
led them to this conclusion they say in
a long molecule
like dna many different permutations are
possible
and it therefore seems likely that the
precise sequence of the bases
is the code which carries the genetical
information
absolutely brilliant and it was actually
predicted ahead of time by
by schroedinger in his book what is life
where he talked about he said that at
the core of life there must be
an aperiodic crystal which is
spectacular he predicted essentially
that that we would discover dna it's
something that was predicted
and then discovered and it is so so
beautiful so incredible to me
and it really does it breaks my heart
that people don't understand the beauty
of this
and it breaks my heart that people
in the atheist community or people who
like to debate with creationists
have actually thrown this aside as well
it started i i was seeing this among
kind of like internet atheists
um who who like to debate with
creationists their way to
to combat this idea that code the
genetic code is real code
codes have to come from a designer what
they were doing is they were attacking
the idea that the genetic code is a code
or that there is code and coded
information in life
they were attacking that they were
saying that it's not it's not really
coded it's just that's just an analogy
and i actually had a professor a biology
professor in the u.s
tell me that i should stop calling it
the genetic code and stop saying that
it's code
that's how far the
opposition has gotten yes no i think
that's the wrong approach i think
it is a code it's definitely a code and
it is a code that's put together
not by a designer but by natural
selection it's very easy to see how that
can happen in principle
details of course need to be worked out
but nevertheless there is no problem
in saying that dna would be a code in
just the same kind of way as
a computer code it certainly is a code
um
you can read it as a code you could you
could even transcribe i think i put this
in
river out of eden could even transcribe
a book
into dna letters and you could read it
out again you could
preserve it in dna and read it again
put it into i think i had a fantasy sort
of science fiction fantasy where
a scientist put some secret
documents uh sort of spy documents into
dna and then
infected himself with a virus to carry
this information and then sneak it out
around the world
right that's that's how code-like it is
it really is completely code-like code
a digital code it's merely quaternary
rather than
uh rather than binary and of course it's
not put together by design it's put
together
by natural selection yeah
yeah i think maybe the best way to go
about this is to just try and talk about
what
information is in general i mean
or we could talk about we could talk
about computer code
in general too because that one of the
things
i think a lot of people in my generation
have difficulty understanding
we think of code as this magical thing
because the computers that we have are
basically like they work like magic to
us smartphones are
so far beyond our comprehension that we
can't make sense of them
whereas when you were first working with
computers things were a lot more
mechanical how they worked was a lot
more obvious
maybe maybe talking about your
experience with that would be helpful
well it's true that i when i've
did in in my career i have had this sort
of rather misbend youth
um and part of that was writing machine
code programs with machine code programs
you really are very close
to the hardware um you're you're writing
in assembly language which is uh
just one removed from writing down ones
and naughts and you have to be very
familiar with the ones and also very
uh acquainted with the idea that it
really is is digital that's well
there's a piece of computer tape which
is very familiar to me because when i
first started
uh computing um we did everything on
punch paper tape like that in america at
the same time they were using punch
cards the same idea
but in britain we had we had um which
british computers had patch paper tape
um and so you really were right down
there
among the digits among the binary digits
from the naughts and ones
and got a very clear conception
of the relationship between writing a
program and actually
putting notes and ones into the computer
you could even correct errors
by changing a one into an order like
literally punching an extra hole
right in that tape or even sticking a
bit of a bit of
tape over a hole that shouldn't be there
that close to it yeah there's so i
i discovered i didn't even know that
these things existed until
uh maybe a couple months ago i started
looking this up i got i was so
interested in the similarity between
these old um punch tape computers and
the ribosome
because it's reading uh it's reading
this a lot like messenger rna you know
you've got uh
you know each what do you call this um
each byte here is um
yes that that's that
that's an 8-bit tape i think yes yeah um
i was i was using first of all five five
bit tapes and then and then eight
tapes yes that's right yeah yes he
actually ordered this online so i got so
excited about this
this is a uh a russian um system
right yes yeah it's
i mean the neat thing about these
computers is
you see that they are just physical
machines i mean the machine physically
interacts with these holes
and you have and that's the holes the
machine is set up in advance in a way so
that it's going to behave in a certain
way
when it hits holes of a certain pattern
and
that's how the computer functions and it
works
in a way tape is better than cards for
that analogy because
cards are discrete objects if you drop
them on the floor it's a
very bad thing i discovered when i went
to america and started having to use
punch cards
but tape is much more like dna because
it's because it is a long
a long string um and and so the the
analogy is even closer in a trivial
sense of course
i think that maybe that's one of the
reasons that people have
difficulty understanding the link
between the genetic code and computer
code is because
you know that that basic machine code
language
is none of us experienced none of us
interact with that anymore
and it actually made me think i wonder
if
if dna hadn't been discovered right
after you know we were
breaking codes in world war ii and then
when people were using stuff like this i
i wonder if it would have taken us
longer to figure out the genetic code or
if we ever
ever even would have if we discovered
dna at the wrong point in history you
know interesting yes that's an
interesting thought
um and you're right of course that
nowadays since we're a little bit
further away from the machine code level
uh we're accustomed to dealing with
computers at a higher level
where we're dealing with whole programs
um
and um it's almost as though
the computers are sort of human i mean
we talk about
it it thinks it's a so-and-so or or um
it it thinks it's talking to the wrong
kind of printer that that kind of thing
we use we use
metaphoric language like thinking um
which is
at a higher level that's rather suitable
actually for
understanding perhaps how the brain
works but for understanding how jeans
work
um the punch paper tape metaphor
is perhaps a bit more suitable
um on the other hand um
there are good analogies which we can
still use uh when i first starting
started programming for the
macintosh um i was no longer using
machine code
i used machine code on pdp-8s and um
yes mostly pdp-8 sorry and and apple ii
of course a lot a lot with apple too um
when i switched to the mac i was no
longer using machine code i was using
high level
languages and there the analogy was
rather nice with other aspects of
genomics because
um when you're programming for
the mac anyway when i was doing it
you have a thing called the toolbox
which is
a set of pre-written routines which do
things like pull down menus
shrinking windows setting up um
those little boxes where you click and
click the mouse in and it changes to
a to a dot or an x um
so those were all toolbox routines which
which were built in
and that's a very good analogy for
what's going on
in the genome people were rather puzzled
when they discovered that the human
genome
is no bigger than that of other mammals
like a mouse for example you sort of
think well
human dignity should require a lot more
information
um actually the genome is about the same
size and the reason is
that both mice and people
in their embryology are calling routines
from the same toolbox of routines
it's just like on on a computer
microsoft word and excel and
all the other programs that we regularly
use they're all
calling upon the same toolbox routines
that's why they look so alike that
that's why the process of pulling down a
menu
or shrinking a window expanding a window
etc
it all looks the same whatever program
you're using and the reason is that
they're all using
the same built-in repertoire of toolbox
routines and it's just like that with
the genome
so the mammalian genome has this set of
toolbox routines
and the difference between a person and
a mouse is the order
in which those toolbox routines are
called so there is a very nice analogy
there
which is at a sort of higher level than
the punch
the tape analogy we were talking about
earlier claude shannon
you know that who came up with
information theory
everything he was doing was based on
communication systems
and it's really neat i've i've got a
quote of his
this is from his his famous paper on the
mathematical theory of communication he
says the fundamental problem
of communication is that of producing at
one point either exactly or
approximately a message
selected at another point in that paper
he goes on to talk about how to
digitize information to make digital
information and what a digital
communication system looks like
and if you look at rna replication which
is you know
a lot of origin of life researchers
think that possibly rna or something
similar to it was the first
the first thing fully capable of
replication in darwinian evolution
and if you look at how rna replication
works
it is exactly this i mean you can
actually describe rna replication with
all of claude shannon's math
as a communication system you start with
the original
chain of rna that is encoded
into a
anti-sense chain of rna which is then
decoded back into a copy of the original
parent
so you have this encoding and decoding
that happens even at the at the
basic level of rna replication and i i
find that really interesting because
that
it suggests that this this digital
nature of things i mean
a nucle a nucleotide either is
replicated or it's not
and there's not really an in-between and
you can get mutations you can get the
wrong nucleotide put there
but it's it's digital information in the
sense that
it's either or and that
stops some of these runaway errors that
would otherwise happen if you're trying
to
create a replication system it stops
noise from getting into the system too
much noise from getting into the system
i agree and and information theory has
been used a lot in
in biology shannon as you know worked
for the bell telephone company and so he
was concerned with the
economics of information transfer
and um so he wanted to think of think of
ways in which
um information could be most
economically encoded and he came with
the idea of the bit
of information as the fundamental unit
of information
information for him meant reduction of
uncertainty and he was actually measured
as reduction of uncertainty and his
formula
measured it like that one of the things
that comes out of
shannon type mathematics is this idea
that
information as a commodity is easily
translated into other media so it
doesn't matter
whether it's in the form of punch paper
tape or
um little lips on um magnetic tape
or a little um noise morse code or
little little noises going down a wire
if if it's in the same if it's
translated from one digital code to
another then it can be faithfully
rendered at the other end
with a certain possibility of error
and i very much like the idea i've been
very inspired by the idea
of information as a commodity which as
you just described it
can be translated from one medium to
another and retains
its value retains its meaning
throughout all these different
translations
shannon was concerned with the economics
of
information transfer such that nothing
is lost or little as possible is lost
different from the semantics from
actually what what the information means
which is a whole separate subject
let's try and unpack this even more so
what is information in general in your
view
and then what is information in genetics
specifically
maybe maybe that could be helpful well
as i said shannon described it as or
measured it as reduction in
uncertainty so when it's when it's
transferred from one
place to another in in human terms
you you start with the idea that there's
a sender and a receiver
and and the receiver doesn't know
something that the sender does know
so um shannon was was aware that
something like
the sun rose this morning contains much
less information than
the sun did not rise this morning
because the receiver already expects
that the sun will rise and therefore
i mean the reduction of of uncertainty
the surprise
value is is is less
so um the one bit of information
is is that which halves your uncertainty
um if you have something like um uh
if if if i turn up a card for an
ordinary pack of cards
and i ask you to guess um the
um the cut the color of the card your
uncertainty is
is exactly um twofold it could be red or
it could be black so if i tell you it's
black
that's one bit of information it's it's
been reduced by one
by what's been divided in in half
um if i tell you it's a it's a heart
um that's two bits of information
because you don't know whether first
whether it's a color and secondly given
that given that it's red say whether it
could be a heart or a diamond so that's
how
he measured information and you can
measure information exactly
in the same way in the genetic code it
being a quaternary code rather than
a binary code it's a little bit more
complicated i have had on my show
dr david fialo and we were talking about
you know what is information in biology
and he was explaining that the base
information in biology is nucleotide
sequences
sequence information is the thing that's
being communicated from parent
to child but that doesn't necessarily
have any sort of meaning to it right it
could be a random chain of rna
for example claude shannon wasn't
interested in meaning he was just
interested in how do you transfer
information from one thing to another
if you talk about this in biological
terms he's interested in
replication how do you get a system
going that can replicate
a chain of rna for example but in
biology we also care about meaning and
what i mean by that is that
you know the the
specific sequences in our dna help us
better survive and reproduce
and what you've so beautifully spent
your career explaining is
really i guess you could say is where
that meaning comes from this is what
darwin explained through the process of
natural selection
as soon as you have a system capable of
replicating
you can get darwinian evolution and just
automatically those sequences which
happen
to be better at reproducing than others
end up becoming more common
in the population and you get this
explosion of
not just information but useful
information information that's useful
in the project of surviving and
reproducing you've written about
these rna experiments where this was
actually demonstrated in
in the lab through spiegelman's monster
right yes so um spiegelman had a a virus
called pubitus an rna virus
says genes are entirely made of rna and
it needs an enzyme
in order to replicate its rna and this
is called uh cubita
replicase yes i'm going to read a
paragraph from the ancestors tale here
spiegelman did something wondrous he set
a form of evolution in motion
in this holy artificial test tube world
with no cells involved at all
imagine is set up as a long row of test
tubes
each containing cubita replicase that's
the enzyme
and raw building blocks but no rna no
rna at all
he seeded the first tube with small
amounts of q beta rna and it duly
replicated lots more copies of itself
he then drew out a small sample of the
liquid
and put a drop of it in the second tube
they've got a whole lot of
tubes one after another representing
generations
when this had been going on for a while
spiegelman drew out a drop from the
second tube and seated the third but
virgin tube and so on spiegelman sampled
the rna in his tubes as the generations
as generations of tubes went by
and monitored its properties including
its potency in infecting bacteria
that these this virus is a phage which
means it's a parasite of bacteria
so it needs to affect bacteria and what
he found was fascinating
the evolving rna became physically
smaller
and smaller and at the same time less
and less infected when bacteria were
offered
it didn't need to infect bacteria
because it was doing it all
in the test tube it was provided with
the necessary
way to live in the test tube after 74
generations 74 tube generations
the typical rna molecule in the tube had
evolved
to a small fraction of the size of its
wild ancestor what was even more
remarkable is
if he did the experiment several times
he always converged upon
the same uh rna
which was called spiegelman's monster or
spiegelman's
mini variant and then later
some german workers did a similar
experiment which was even more
remarkable under some conditions a test
tube containing no
rna at all just the raw materials for
making rna
plus the q beta replicates enzyme can
spontaneously generate
self-replicating rna which under the
right circumstances
will evolve to become similar to
spiegelman's monster
so here we have a beautiful example of
convergent evolution in a test tube
starting from not quite nothing but
something very close to nothing
certainly there's absolutely no creator
involved there some people might think
oh well the rna got smaller it got
simpler
that's not really all that interesting
what actually happened is that the
the sequence evolved and adapted to its
new environment its new environment
had different requirements than its
environment when it was you know part of
the genome of a virus
and it adapted specifically to
those requirements it optimized it it
optimizes
for its own replication and there's a
wonderful paper by gerald joyce called
40 years of in vitro evolution and it's
free online
everyone should read this it's amazing
but
he goes over a bunch of follow-up
experiments they through different
problems different challenges at these
evolving chains of rna and they would
they would increase in complexity quite
dramatically
to accomplish all sorts of things
there's even a medication
that was evolved it was an evolved chain
of rna that's used as medicine
for for years it it would it prevents
the onset of blindness
and aging we now have a
i think it's an antibody version of the
same drug
that's easier to store and so it's
cheaper
so the rna one is no longer being used
but
rnas i mean it's evolving chains of rna
it's
it can they can solve real problems
meaningful information
emerges simply as a consequence of
replication
replication with mutations plus
selection
yeah it is very amazing and it
completely gives the lie to anybody to
think you have to have a creator
to start these things off it really does
show with an increase in complexity
increase in adaptive efficiency
as the generations go by the big
question in origin of life research is
how do you get the first
replicator and that it's still
unanswered i mean we don't
the first replicator capable of
open-ended evolution you know rna is a
thing capable of this
but rna an rna replication system is
probably not prebiotically plausible but
this is what origin of life researchers
are looking for they're looking for
a prebiotically plausible system like
this that could have emerged
on the early earth because once you have
darwinian evolution you can have
you've got information replicating you
can get functional information to evolve
and the whole game just explodes
once you've got replication once you've
got dna going
and you're you're right that um um
dna is definitely not a viable system
on its own rna kind of is
but as you say it's not prebiotic
prebiotically viable
it's hard to see how you can actually
get run so there has to be something
before that and that's okay um we
haven't found it yet
but um it's something rna is a very good
bridge and our
rna is a better one than dna because
rna does function as an enzyme dna
doesn't dna needs enzymes
rna functions as its own enzyme
and so it's it's it's a better one but
we need something before
rna to get to get that going and as you
say is one of the unsolved
puzzles um it's not a totally baffling
puzzle i mean it's not sort of
profoundly difficult it will be solved
probably it hasn't been solved yet
yeah yeah i i'm quite confident
it will have we're not going to know
exactly what happened at the origin of
life but we'll have a
a model that works start to finish i
don't know when
but it's i've worked with the center for
chemical evolution we did a whole series
there's a video the rna world hypothesis
where we show
a chain of rna can act as a replicator
so it can act as a genotype
and that can fold up into a
three-dimensional shape that has a
phenotype
so you actually have the genotype
phenotype transition with one molecule
which is
absolutely amazing when you look at
the ribosome for example which is
the structure in our cells it's doing
all the protein coding
the functional bits of that the the core
the catalytic core the ribosome is
just a chain of rna it's it's a chain of
rna that's doing all that which
suggests that before we had
directed protein coding which is what we
have in cells now
we had evolving chains of rna that we're
replicating somehow
suggest that we don't know for certain
at this point but
i have a question for you that might
seem like it's taken us way off topic
but it's actually not i
this is relevant to the origin of the
genetic code
the label that you have for your career
is ethologist so you're studying
animal behavior right yes have you did
have you focused much on the the origin
of signaling i know stuart west who
well i wrote two papers jointly with
john krebs
about signaling and the
burden of those really was to refute the
then fashionable idea among ethologists
that
animal communication is all about
cooperative transfer of information
so the assumption was made by people
like mile maestro nico tinbergen and and
others of his
his colleagues was that social life
needs kind of oiling the wheels need
oiling by
um smooth-running communication and
the the signaler needs to be understood
by the
receiver of the signal and and vice
versa
what krebs and i substituted for that
was
a more manipulative approach we thought
that
um the selfish gene we're looking at
life was not really compatible with this
highly cooperative vision
of animal signals and so um
when something like a um
a male bird sings and uh
this causes the ovaries of the female to
grow which
it does that's known physiologically
it's been shown in
doves and in canaries we saw krebs and i
saw it
as a manipulation we made the analogy
with
uh the human experimenter who by
injecting hormones
into the female bird could cause her
ovaries to grow
or uh the physiologist who sticks
electrodes into the brain
of an animal and makes it behave rather
like a puppeteer pulling strings
we saw the influence of one animal on
another via signals
as equivalent to that so the the male
bird is trying to influence the behavior
of the female bird or the or
of another male perhaps to intimidate
if the male bird was a physiologist
capable of in
of injecting hormones or capable of
sticking electrodes into the brain of
the rival
or the prospective mate then he would do
so but he can't do that
what he can do is enter the brain
of the victim use the word advisedly
by the portholes which already exist
which are the eyes and ears and nose etc
and that's what he does and so animal
signals crabs and eyesore as
manipulation direct influences
on the physiology of the
uh victim animal and i tie this up with
my
idea of the extended phenotype which is
another book that i wrote
where the behavior of the victim can be
thought of
as part of the phenotypic expression of
genes
in the manipulator
and the cuckoo is a classic example of
this where
the cuckoo is a parasite but unlike
parasites which live
inside the body of the host where
parasitologists have already established
uh very strong evidence for
physiological direct physiological
evidence
of the parasite on the host i would call
extended phenotypic expression of the
genes of the parasite in the phenotype
of the host
in the case of the cuckoo the parasite
is not living
inside the host the parasite is sitting
outside the host but nevertheless
exerting just the same
kind of influence as a parasite of say a
fluke
say or a tapeworm being inside the host
this is
direct manipulation and krebs and i
generalized this
to the notion that all animal signals
are manipulative in the same kind of way
as the cuckoo manipulating its host
we call i i call that action at a
distance
well the um
would it would always be considered
manipulative if it's helping both
individuals because there are a bunch of
communications that happen that help
both individuals
exactly yeah yeah i could say that that
the mating call is one like the female
wants to reproduce as well as the male
it's
both of their best interests right yeah
good good point and
in those cases where it is in both of
their best interests
then the point we made was that rather
than shouting which is what much of
animal signals is about
either literally auditory shouting or
visual shouting
bright colors loud voices and so on
you don't need that if the victim is no
longer
a victim but is actually a co-operator
it actually wants to be manipulated so
to speak
then the signal ceases to be a shout and
becomes what we called a conspiratorial
whisper
and so you tend to get a decrease in
um in intensity of the signal in those
cases where the signal
increases in those cases where the
signal gets louder and louder
over evolutionary time or brighter and
brighter
over evolutionary time then our
interpretation would be
that that is a is a manifestation of
resistance on the part of the
signal lee on the part of the victim so
where the victim is resisting being
manipulated
you expect the signal to become louder
and louder
and where the victim is cooperating
wants to be manipulated in other words
manipulation isn't really even
appropriate
where that happens then the signal drops
in volume and becomes a conspiratorial
whisper
so so quiet that maybe the experiment
maybe the ethologist scarcely even
notices it
so the reason that i wanted to go off on
this little side tangent of
signaling theory and how it is that
these these communication
systems evolve is that you know the the
base level of information
in biology is just sequence information
we talked about
rnas can replicate and they can you've
got
the genotype is the phenotype and a
chain of rna but
in protein coding we have quite a
bit of complexity there you've got a
bunch of evolved ribozymes
you've got messenger rna you've got the
ribosomal rna legitimate ribozyme
rna enzyme you've got transfer rna
and then in the modern system you've got
a bunch of proteins that are helping
everything happen as well
there's a lot of coordinated efforts and
i think if we were to look at this from
a signaling theory perspective
there's a lot of conspiratorial
whispering happening
there's very tight cooperation and
coordination
in the genetic code in protein coding in
that whole process
and i i imagine that if we were to apply
signaling theory really strictly to this
we could
we could probably produce models that
show an evolution of this maybe from
from more of a parasitic origin where
you have
the uh the ribosome is starting to
evolve and it's it's got this ability to
take and
grab amino acids out of its surrounding
and smash them together into in and form
these little protein little peptides
and it's using those to maybe stabilize
itself so it can survive
greater temperature variants you know
between
bouts of replication and other
chains of rna are evolving to exploit
this
and to you know attach on to the
ribosome
the primitive version of the ribosome
and manipulate it in certain ways
to get benefits from its its behavior
and i i feel
like we could use signaling theory
even to study the evolution of something
like the origin of the genetic code
the origin of this protein coding system
that of course is at the chemical at the
biochemical level
but um people like me who look at whole
animals are interested in the um end
phenotypic products which are also the
products of
of the proteins that are made and so
something like
the shape of an animal the shape of its
wing the color of the feathers
uh the length of the crest the shape of
the teeth
all these visible external
externally visible phenotypic
characteristics so ultimately
the product of changes in genes which
work through a chain reaction
of starting with proteins and then
working through the influence of
proteins on embryology
every stage of embryonic development is
influenced by the proteins which are
produced by the genes which are produced
by
natural selection ultimately and so
you're looking at the chemical level
where the effects are
immediate yeah
at the proximal end of the chain and i'm
looking at the distal end of the chain
after a long series of events that have
been
um a cascade of events in embryology
which result in the external
manifestations including behavior of
course which is just a manifestation of
the nervous system
it's all the same stuff going on it's
just at the end of a longer chain of
causation
yeah yeah this conversation has been
wonderful
richard i i want to try and wrap things
up by
hopefully talking about the ending of
your book
the river out of eden where you talk
about this concept
of an information bomb what is this
information bomb
well um in the last chapter of river art
of eden
um i had this rather sort of science
fictiony flavored
chapter the information bomb replication
bomb
and i began with the the analogy with
a supernova if you look out into the
heavens
once every century or so you may see a
supernova a great flare up
of extreme energy in some part of the
solar system
well the information bomb is another
kind of flare-up
it's it's not um visible as a flash of
light
uh it doesn't become visible until later
but what it is
is the rare discovery probably rare
discovery
of replication on our planet it happened
when the origin of life happened
when rna probably rna and then d and
anyway dna eventually produced
um eat life and so you've got a great
flowering an
explosion of living things
um which culminated in humanity which is
capable of
actually leaving the home planet first
in the form of radio waves
uh which have already left the planet of
course and it could be picked up in as
expanding shell expanding sphere of
influence
and then finally in the form of
spaceships rockets which can go
elsewhere in the universe
um so this is like a kind of supernova
it takes longer to develop but it is a
kind of bomb it's a kind of explosion
it has a quieter beginning uh but it
could have
a very momentous ending if um as science
fiction writers
speculate we do spread to other parts of
the cosmos so that's the replication
bomb or the information bomb it starts
with
the spontaneous arising on a planet
somewhere in the universe
of self-replication self-replication
then sets in motion a chain reaction
which is life natural selection
darwinian natural selection
no doubt in different forms in different
different planets
but the result is an explosion of life
which culminates
in a form of life which is capable of
intelligence and capable of technology
capable of technology
and is capable of reaching out beyond
the home planet uh rather like a
supernova
i loved that part of this book it just
i mean i'm sure you're familiar with the
pale blue dot carl sagan's
uh yes poem you know where he he talks
about the the humble earth and how
it just it's just a poem about humility
and
i was when i was reading this your
information bomb
i i i realized it's actually possible
that this
humble pale blue dot could consume the
galaxy i mean we could actually send out
we could actually send out uh
bits of information that first emerged
here that go
everywhere i'm actually traveling to
is is is a stiff a stiffer proposition
carl taken himself speculated other
science fiction writers have speculated
that this
could happen um that's much more
difficult than
broadcasting radio waves which were
already
and could increase the intensity of
those yes it's a it's a nice science
fiction
concept yeah how do you feel about our
chances of making it to the point
where we could actually get out there
right far
it's kind of funny because i i mean my
whole excitement about
science in science education there's a
dark side to it where
we are our our power
is increasing exponentially because of
science
yet our wisdom to
you know use it properly is not growing
exponentially
along with that i mean we have
the potential with virus engineering all
sorts of things
it seems almost uh yeah inevitable that
something horrible could happen
yes the dark side uh it is a worry
and um
i'm i'm more excited than worried but
but
um you that you you but i think you are
right to be worried i
i believe in science i think science can
be such a force for good it can be a
force for bad as well if it's misused
the trick of course is to use it well um
it
it it's an immensely powerful weapon
which
in the the right hands can do enormous
amounts of good and in the wrong hands
can do enormous amounts of bad
and and the trick is to keep it out of
the wrong hands
the trick is to keep it out of the wrong
hands i think that's a pretty good place
to end
our conversation really
and that's i mean that's what science
education i think really is all about
the more people who
understand how these things work the
more
minds can comprehend what's going on in
these labs and
in different industries the better our
chances are
of of actually keeping this system in
check
and preventing something horrible from
happening so richard
i i really i appreciate the work that
you've done
helping more people understand how this
world works
how the scientific process works thank
you bye